So I didn't think I
was gonna be ready to share this with y'all,
but some of my merch just came in.
Look at this.
Super fuzzy on the inside,
universal sizing,
um, cute, mouthy,
and opinionated.
So if you know anybody like that,
this is the perfect sweatshirt for them.
I also have some other options.
We've got mind your own motherhood
for your favorite nosy Karen.
For those with the even sassier sense of humor,
we have mind your own titties.
Works for girls,
gals, theys everyone.
And last but not least,
vintage style,
not vintage values.
This one's a little bit more of a niche one,
but I love it.
Love the pin up. Super cute.
The link is in my bio,
so go check it out.